[Musique]
chirac c'est sur jacob avait décidé de
placer la rentrée politique des
républicains sous le signe de la
jeunesse est bien le pari a été réussi
puisque nous étions plus de 1000 jeunes
rassemblés à brailler pour discuter
débattre et réfléchir collectivement à
l'avenir de notre pays le républicain
nous pensons qu'il est urgent de mettre
fin à la politique désastreuse menée par
emmanuel maintenant à droite
notre projet est clair la défense du
travail d'abord parce que le travail est
la condition permettant l'émancipation
individuelle de chacun
l'ordre et la sécurité car partout en
france les violences explosent dans un
climat d'impunité généralisée l'écologie
enfin et pas n'importe laquelle une
écologie du bon sens humaniste et
populaire alors je vous propose
d'adhérer de ré adhérer aux républicains
pour construire ensemble la france
[Musique]